in the next series of videos i'm going
to give my best attempt to trying to get
a handle on the bailout and the
financial crisis and so i'm going to try
to explain
different concepts in more than one way
and then i think hopefully it'll all
sink in but the big picture really is is
that there's a lot of fancy terminology
being thrown around but but the
underlying concepts
really aren't that fancy so i i think a
good place to start is just with the
idea of the balance sheet and you could
watch some of the videos that i did
before the whole financial mess on the
balance sheet and they'll give you a
good primer but it doesn't hurt to
review it here so a balance sheet is
just a snapshot of what you have and
what you owe and the difference between
and the difference between is kind of
like your wealth so if i just had a a
personal balance sheet i could write my
assets
so my assets and they mean what you
think they mean these are things that
will give you future benefits so let's
say my assets i have i don't know let's
say i have a thousand dollars cash
to have a thousand dollars cash
let's say i have a
i don't know let's say i have a hundred
a hundred thousand dollar
house
let's say i have a
ten thousand dollar car
and i don't know let's say all
everything else
you know i'll call it
other in my furniture and i don't know
my my tv and everything else i don't
know is another five thousand dollars
so those would be my assets and so what
are my total assets see thousand hundred
ten thousand no it's a hundred and one
thousand hundred eleven thousand hundred
and sixteen thousand dollars
one hundred sixteen thousand dollars
well it would be great if we lived in a
world of only assets but unfortunately
let's say that i had liabilities as well
so liabilities
liabilities
and these th a liability is what you
think it means it means something that
you you have to give future economic
benefit for you're kind of on the hook
for something and so let's say my
liabilities i don't know let's say i
have a
twenty thousand dollar student loan
and let's say on that house
unfortunately i don't own it outright
let's say that i have a eighty thousand
dollar mortgage on that house so
essentially i borrowed eighty thousand
dollars
from the bank but and let's throw some
credit card debt in there just make this
realistic relative to i think a lot of
households out there let's say that
there's five thousand dollars of credit
card debt although for most households
right now this house is a lot more and
this mortgage is a lot more but anyway
we'll
i won't make social commentary this is
just to explain what a balance sheet is
so
what is left over for me what is my
assets minus my liability so let me
let's calculate our total liabilities
so this is total assets i'll use it with
an a colon so what are my total
liabilities 20 plus 80 plus 5. so it's
and five thousand dollars
hundred five thousand total liabilities
so the difference between these two my
assets minus my liabilities this is
essentially my net worth right this is
if if i just liquidated everything
tomorrow if i sold all of this and paid
off all this this is what i would be
left standing with that's my net worth
or you could view that as that is my
equity you often hear equity in the
context of a house in the context of a
house is just the asset of the house
minus the liability but i'm talking
about in the context of my personal
balance sheet not that these are the
actual numbers i don't want to give away
too much about my life at this just just
yet but anyway so what is that number
here so my equity and i'll do that in a
i'll make it green since that's if it's
positive it's a good number
my equity is a hundred sixteen thousand
minus a hundred five thousand so what is
that that's eleven thousand dollars
eleven thousand dollars that's my equity
so there's a couple of things to you
know think about here you know you'll
maybe a lot you'll you'll meet people
with a you know a hundred thousand
dollar house or a million dollar house
and they say oh i am worth a million
dollars and well you're like well you're
not really worth a million dollars
unless you own that house outright and
you could actually sell that house for a
million dollars it's not what you paid
for it's what you could the market's
willing to give for it but your real net
worth is your assets minus all of your
liabilities so in this case your net
worth is actually 11 000
not a hundred and sixteen thousand
dollars and this is another important
thing to to think about
assets are always equal to liabilities
plus equity and that just comes out of
the definition of what equity is equity
was assets minus liabilities but you
know when you if you take an mba they'll
they'll write it down and it looks like
an equation but it's you know assets is
equal to liabilities plus equity but
that's that's almost
a by definition that that's going to be
true so so what can we do with this how
does this help us well there's a there's
a couple of ways that we can we can
think about this first of all what
happens if my liabilities are larger
than my assets
so if i owe the world more than the
world owes me
well then this number is going to be
negative right and if this number is
negative then there's no really good
reason for me maybe to preserve my
credit score but other than that if we
put credit scores if we take that out of
the equation
there's no good reason for me to
continue living this existence if my
liabilities are greater than my assets
so let's say let's let's think about
that situation let's say that
my house is only worth a hundred
thousand but for whatever reason
i owe a hundred twenty thousand dollars
to the bank let's say maybe i originally
bought the house with a no money down
payment for a hundred twenty thousand
dollars
and now i'm honest with myself i'm like
you know what the value has gone down
it's only worth a hundred thousand now
so i'm in this situation where you could
say i'm upside down my mortgage well one
you could say there's no incentive for
me to continue paying this house an even
bigger picture if i now look at my if i
now look at my balance sheet what are my
liabilities now 140 my liabilities would
be 145 000
and my equity would be my assets minus
my liabilities so 116 minus 45 what is
that 20 minus 29 000
so i'll do that in red because that's a
bad number for your equity minus 29
so in this situation
in this situation there's really no
reason for me to continue living like
the way i am at least financially
there's no you should you know as long
as you're breathing there's no reason
not to continue breathing but you
wouldn't want to live like this
financially anymore so there's no reason
not to go seek bankruptcy protection and
bankruptcy protection is essentially
saying is admitting or i am insolvent
which means that there's no way that i'm
going to be able to unwind all of my
liabilities courts protect me my lenders
can't come back after me everything is
going to be erased they're going to take
all my assets all my liabilities and
they're essentially going to take these
and divide them up amongst the people
that i owe stuff to so that's bankruptcy
that's insolvency and i i want to
highlight the word insolvency
insolvency
because that's a word that we're going
to touch on when we actually talk about
the credit crisis and that is opposed to
illiquidity so what is illiquidity so
illiquidity so insolvencies means
there's no reason for you to continue
with this type of a financial situation
you're bankrupt you go get bankruptcy
protection that's insolvency
illiquidity is a different situation
illiquidity says no i actually do have
positive equity so let me
let me go back to the original
circumstance
let me
let me go back so let's let me just go
back to the original circumstance
it really was i only owe 80 000 on the
house so my liabilities really are only
105 000.
so i really do have a positive equity
of eleven thousand dollars
but let's say
let's say so this isn't insolvency more
so i'm going to describe what
illiquidity means to you
or to me in this case because this is my
balance sheet
so let's say that um i don't know a uh
my my uh my my wife comes to me and says
oh you know we need to pay our child
tuition um it is five thousand dollars
for the upcoming year i need to pay five
thousand dollars in tuition so i need to
pay five thousand dollars
pay five thousand actually let me take a
a better situation because if i'm
talking about tuition it should have
shown up on liabilities let's say that i
have to make a five thousand dollar
payment on my student loan so there's i
had some kind of weird student loan
where five thousand dollars comes due
all of a sudden so i have to make a five
thousand dollar payment on student loan
so let me do that in red
make five thousand dollar payment
5k payment
and it could be for anything but let's
say it's to satisfy part of one of these
liabilities
so if you look at my equity if you look
at my assets my minus my liabilities i
clearly have eleven thousand dollars i
am worth eleven thousand dollars and if
i could liquidate all my assets and all
my liabilities overnight i would have
eleven thousand dollars in cash and then
i could pay that five thousand dollars
in fact in the process of doing it i
would have paid that five thousand
dollars
but in this circumstance if i just look
at my situation let's say that student
loan payment is due tomorrow
i only have a thousand dollars of cash
right i only have a thousand dollars
maybe sitting in my checking account so
i can't make that five thousand dollar
payment just with my cash and then i
look at everything else i'm like boy can
i unload any of these assets overnight
well a house absolutely not there's no
way i'm going to be able to unload my
house tomorrow maybe if i didn't you
know i could find someone who'd buy it
for 50 000 tomorrow but that wouldn't
help my situation then i'm going my
equity essentially will go negative
again so that won't help i can't sell my
car overnight uh you know maybe i could
sell it at a super low price for four
thousand dollars just to kind of make
this payment but i don't want to do that
either and same thing your furniture
that's something you know you'd have to
go on craigslist and and and take
pictures of it you couldn't do it so
this is a situation where you are you're
having a liquidity crisis you are
illiquid but you're not insolvent you
have
positive you have a positive net worth
if assuming that you're not lying about
what's going on your balance sheet and
that's another issue
so how do you get past a liquidity
crisis like this well someone has to
give you we could call it a bridge loan
because they're giving you a financial
bridge from here to where you need to
get to go or they're giving you a bridge
that essentially buys you time right
let's say your your dad says okay sal
i'm or my dad i guess i'll give you a
five thousand dollar loan for the next
two months and over the next two months
i expect you to find some other source
of cash maybe sell your car buy a
cheaper car sell some your furniture or
something so that is a loan to prevent a
liquidity crisis and that loan wouldn't
be a bad idea because if this person
isn't lying about their balance sheet or
if i'm not lying about my balance sheet
then i actually am good for the money on
the other hand that loan would be a bad
idea if i had insolvency because it
would just be throwing good money after
bad it's
i wouldn't i'm not able to pay my
current loans and you're just giving me
another loan that i wouldn't be able to
pay anyway i'm out of time i'll see you
in the next video